Have you ever noticed how badly people behave
when they are collecting their luggage at
the airport?
I mean they all cluster right up against the
carousel so people behind them can’t see
their bags.
And then when you do spot your bag, you have
to push through all the other passengers to
collect it and usually bump into them as you
are grabbing your bag off the carousel.
Why is it that people behave so badly?
It doesn’t seem to matter which airport
you go to anywhere in the world.
The problem is the same.
And this problem, believe it or not, is related
to why trees are tall.
Go with me on this.
So why are trees this tall?
I mean some of them are over 115 meters.
They are the largest organisms on the planet.
And you might think that they are this tall
so that they can capture sunlight.
And to a degree that is true.
But anyone who has ever walked through a mature
forest knows that the lower part of a tree
has basically no branches and leaves.
And that makes sense, because not enough light
filters down through the top most branches
to make it worth having sun capturing apparatus
down here.
Over millennia trees have evolved to put their
energy where it yields returns, that is, in
the canopy and not where it doesn’t.
But this then begs the question: Why put all
this energy into building a trunk that is
10 or 20 meters if you are never intending
to use this vertical space to capture sunlight?
I mean, it costs energy to make this trunk.
Plus it makes it harder to transport water
from the roots up to the topmost branches
and it makes the tree more susceptible to
water stress.
So it is in every individual tree’s best
interest to be shorter, to not have this gigantic
trunk and to use the conserved energy to improve
its seeds and its branches, to put its energy
where it pays a return.
But, of course, if there was a mutation that
allowed a tree to do this, you know what would
happen to it.
In a forest surrounded by all these taller
trees, it would be shaded from the sun and
so it would wither and die.
But what if all of the trees developed the
same mutation?
What if they all created a friendship pact,
a forest of friendship in which everyone agreed
not to grow such a big trunk, to star the
leaves right at the ground?
Well, that would mean every individual tree
would be better off.
The trouble is this solution is not stable,
because any tiny mutation that results in
a tree that is slightly taller would advantage
that tree.
It would be able to capture more light and
it would shade its neighbors.
And so pretty soon it would have more offspring.
It would come to dominate the forest.
And then any additional mutation down then
line would result in even taller trees.
This is how trees got so tall.
I mean, they would keep getting taller until
the cost of going one more foot is exactly
equal to benefits of collecting that additional
sunlight.
And that is why trees are as tall as they
are today.
I mean, it is not an optimal solution.
It is not like these trees have the best use
of their energy.
But it is the one that is stable.
So the point is: Although it is in every tree’s
best interest to be a part of this forest
of friendship, it will never work.
It will never last, because any individual
who gets a little bit taller is going to ruin
it for everyone.
And it is the very same thing when you go
to collect your bags.
I mean, if everyone could agree to stand a
couple of meters away from the carousel, everyone
would have a good view of their bags and be
able to easily step forward and collect their
luggage.
But, of course, one person standing forward
is going to block the view of behind them.
So everyone is going to rush forward.
It is an unstable solution, just like a forest
of friendship.
So remember.
Next time you are frustrated collecting your
bags at the airport, remember.
Trees know just how you feel.
>> I have summarized the whole problem for
you here.
Are you ready?